general jack keane is with me now and
general good morning to you we begin a
brand new week here it appears that
putin's army has yes they continue to
hit different parts of the country they
have not achieved acquiring more
territory generally speaking how do you
see the battlefield today general
yeah well what they've done over the
weekend bill is they certainly
they they increased the
the level of war and violence against
civilians there's no doubt about it but
they made absolutely no territorial
gains against the ukrainian military uh
over the weekend and they have expanded
the war as they said
uh on the weekend that they would begin
to attack those who are resupplying and
the resupply lanes into ukraine and so
that's what that uh so-called training
base is about i don't think the russians
care that it was a training base in the
past they care that it's a
staging base
for resupply that is why they hit it and
they will certainly try to interdict
other
routes of resupply that have taken place
coming into ukraine so for our audience
to understand americans are involved in
a resupply on the polish side of the
border but are not involved in the
resupply nor any nato nations involved
in any resupply activities on the
ukrainian side of the border
general there continues to be calls to
arm up ukraine uh lindsey graham with
maria just on sunday morning roll this
first watch
the biden administration stop that
transfer one minute they're saying
they're not using the planes we have but
if we give them more it'd be world war
three so what happened is that putin
threatened biden and he folded like a
cheap suit give them the planes well if
they're i don't know if they're going to
get the planes in time jenna we'll see
wall street journal editorial board
russia's war gets closer to nato
putin is exploiting biden's red lines
against u.s involvement that has to do
with the hit on the the military base
there near the polish border how do you
see this sir
and are we ready for it if it comes to
that
well what putin is saber-rattling and
he's trying to get inside our head
certainly and i think to some degree he
has you know threatening
uh an escalation of the war with nato
just think about that putin's got the
better part of his army in ukraine
and they're struggling
they're not making progress
and he's going to go go to war with nato
without out guns him out mans them out
finances in four to five to one don't
think so
he's also threatening the use of wmd
he's doing this
because he wants to paralyze the binding
administration
from
increasing their support
obviously to the ukrainians and also to
back off on on the sanctions
we got to stand up to this that obama
and
biden have the same problem they get
paralyzed by the fear of adverse
consequence and in this case it's
escalation
you've got to have some spine to deal
with the threats of an adversary like
putin who who uses force and obvious is
a barbarian and brutal in killing
civilians but you have to stand up to
him not not just
what we're doing in terms of providing
support but also stand up to him uh in
terms of our own rhetoric uh in dealing
with his with his rhetoric so i think
that the big thing is is a fiasco i mean
the polls manipulated us to trade in old
migs for new f6 teams we couldn't give
them those because they're going to
taiwan we should have wire brushed the
poles at that point and said look at
guys
if you want to continue to get the kind
of aid from us that you want you're
going to you made a public declaration
you're going to support the ukrainians
we're going to hold you to that
give them the airplanes and that's where
it should have ended and as opposed to
this humiliation of fiasco we got into
with lincoln saying yes it's a good deal
and then coming back later and saying
well notice this could escalate yeah it
makes no sense i have 15 seconds here
how
what is your level of confidence that
you have in the biden team
that is in place right now
that has made decisions over the past 19
days sometimes they're head scratchers
as as just you point out
how good is this team do you think sir
well i i give them some credit for
certainly unifying the transatlantic
alliance
bringing a world condemnation down on
russia i think they've done a very good
job releasing information about russia
intent and then i think at times
thwarting thoughting that a tent
but i i don't think we've ever been all
in to the degree that we should be in
terms of arms and ammunitions they need
right now
ukrainians need integrated air defense
systems to deal with the aerial
bombardments that's taken place and we
should be getting them to them i'm
hoping that we are
and i think we have to show even more
determination and resolve in terms of
dealing with putin and and his sort of
inflammatory threats that he's making
general thank you from your lips right
jack keem will speak many times this
week thank you sir for coming on today
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now